is it possible to design standardized
tests
that do get that are useful to college
admissions well they already exist the
sat is highly correlated with many
aspects of success at college here's the
problem so maybe you could speak to this
the correlation across the population
versus individuals
so
um
you know our criminal justice system is
designed
to make sure
um
well
it's it's it's still there's tragic
cases where innocent people go go go to
jail but you try to avoid that in the
same
way with testing it just
it would suck for an sat to miss genius
yes and it it's possible but it's
statistically unlikely so the so it
really comes down to
yeah do which
piece of information
maximizes
your
decision making ability
so
if you just use high school grades
it's okay
but you will miss some people who just
don't do well in high school but who are
actually pretty smart smart enough to be
bored silly in high school and they
don't care and they their high school
gpa isn't that good so you will miss
them
in the same sense
that somebody who could be
very uh able and ready for college just
doesn't do well on their s.a.t this is
why
you make decisions with of
taking in a variety of in information
the other thing i wanted to say
i talked about when you make a decision
for an individual statistically
for groups there are many people
who have a disparity between their math
score and their verbal score that
disparity or the other way around that
disparity is called tilt
the score is tilted one way or the other
and that tilt has been studied
empirically to see what that predicts
and in fact you can't make predictions
about
about college success
uh based on on tilt and mathematics is a
good example there are many people
especially non-native speakers of
english who come to this country take
the sats do very well on the math and
not so well on the verbal well if
they're applying to a math program
the professors there who are making the
decision or the admissions officers
don't weight so much the score on verbal
especially if it's a non-native speaker
well so yeah you have to
try to in the admission process bring in
the context
but non-native isn't really the problem
i mean that was part of the problem for
me but it's the the anxiety was which
it's interesting
it's interesting
um
oh boy reducing yourself down to numbers
but it's still true it's still the truth
well it's a it's a painful that same
anxiety that led me to be
um
to struggle with the s.a.t um verbal
tests
is still within within me
in all ways of life
so maybe that's not anxiety
maybe that's something
you know like personality is also pretty
stable
personality is stable
personality
does impact
the way you navigate life yeah uh
there's no question
yeah and we should say that g factor in
intelligence is not just about some kind
of
number on a paper it also has to do with
how you navigate life
how um
easy life is for you
in this very complicated world so
personality is all tied into that in
some in some some deep fundamental way
but now you've hit the key point about
why we even want to study intelligence
and personality i think to a lesser
extent but
that's my interest is more on
intelligence i went to graduate school
and wanted to study personality but
uh that's kind of another story how i
got kind of shifted from personality
research over to intelligence research
because it's not just a number
intelligence is not just an iq score
it's not just an sat score it's what
those numbers reflect
about your ability to navigate everyday
life
it has been said
that life is one long intelligence test
[Laughter]
and who can't relate to that
and if you doubt see another problem
here is a lot of critics of intelligence
research intelligence testing
tend to be academics who by and large
are pretty smart people
and pretty smart people by and large
have enormous difficulty understanding
what the world is like for people with
iqs of 80
or 75
it is a completely different everyday
experience
even
iq scores of 85 90.
you know there's a popular television
program judge judy where judge judy
deals with
everyday people with everyday problems
and you can see the full range
of problem solving ability demonstrated
there
and sometimes she does it for laughs but
it really isn't funny because
people
who who are
there are people who are very limited in
their life navigation let alone success
by having
by by not having good reasoning skills
which cannot be taught
we know this by the way because there
are many efforts you know the united
states military which excels at training
people
i mean i don't know that there's a
better organization in the world for
training diverse people
and they won't take people with iqs
under i think 83 is the cut off
because they have found you
they are unable to train
people with lower iqs to do jobs in the
military so one of the things that g
factor has to do with his learning
absolutely some people learn
faster than others
some people learn
more than others now faster by the way
is not necessarily better
as long as you get to the same place
eventually
but you know there are professional
schools that want students who can learn
the fastest because they can learn more
or learn deeper or
all kinds of of uh
ideas about why you select people with
the highest scores and there's nothing
funnier by the way
to listen to a bunch of academics
complain about the concept of
intelligence and intelligence testing
and then you go to a faculty meeting
where they're discussing who to hire
among the applicants and all they talk
about is how smart the person is
you